[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les heures lourde de ce 11 novembre
dominée par la tension algériennes ont
été éclairées par le geste du président
de la république déposant une gerbe
devant la statue de georges clemenceau
avant d'aller s'incliner devant la tombe
du soldat inconnu
leurs lourdes éclairer encore par
l'enthousiasmé populaire sur les champs
elysées devant le défilé d'une armée
fidèle à son rôle national
je
alger le délégué général monsieur de
l'ouvrier déposé une gerbe devant le
monument aux morts mais au calme de
paris au cours de ces heures consacrée
au souvenir devait se poser le tumulte
d'alger en dépit des forces de police
considérable une foule de manifestants
s'est massé consommation reste sans
effet les manifestants des jeunes gens
presque uniquement vont se poser pendant
plusieurs heures aux crs et gendarmes
mobiles
un contrat plus de 100 blessés parmi le
service d'ordre et les manifestants
quand on remettra en marche les
trolleybus utilisé comme barika
[Musique]
londres vient de faire connaissance avec
le scooter soucoupes volantes cet
appareil conçu selon le même principe
que la voiture sans roux glissent comme
elle sur un coussin d'air et voyagent
aussi bien sur l'eau que sur terre cet
engin mesure trois mètres de diamètre et
comme il n'a pas besoin de routes
son encombrement ne nuira pas à son
succès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois mètres de diamètre sur deux mètres
cinquante d'épaisseur telles sont les
dimensions de la soucoupe plongeante
cette fois mais au point par le
commandant cousteau pour l'exploration
sous-marine deux hommes peuvent-ils
tenir à condition de rester assise ou
couchée l'engin mise à l'eau par
l'intermédiaire d'un pas lent depuis le
bord du navire laboratoire la calypso
entreprises s'est plongée autonome près
des côtes méditerranéennes
chaque fois même rituel et ses dépenses
voué au prix sous marine des
branchements du téléphone la liaison
s'effectue en temps plongé par radio des
larghi départ le phare de position
la calypso va suivre ces évolutions
jusqu'au moment où des jets d'eau sur la
mer signaleront son retour en surface
jusqu'à 400 mètres de profondeur la
soucoupe a pu ausculter la vie sous
marine
[Musique]
et bien non non ce n'était pas le même
l'église de nurlu dans la somme est bien
la seule au moins en france et peut-être
même dans le monde à posséder un double
desservant labetur cris est en effet à
un double curé ou plutôt les abbés
tueries sont jumeaux
tellement jumeaux pourrait-on dire qu'à
tous les âges on a pu les prendre l'un
pour l'autre
ils ont dit ensemble leur première messe
et ne se sont jamais séparés
vous êtes monsieur le curé jean-pierre
et vous êtes monsieur le curé pour
annoncer - berges ans oui les en pierre
vous avez 50 50 ans et vous êtes frère
jumeau et vous administrez la même
paroisse de nouilles ou en cinquante ans
de vie commune
vous vous êtes quitté très peu souvent
très très peur mais il sauf 17 jours en
ça paraît un siècle avec jean-pierre
vous est la réplique exacte de l'abbé
pierre jean les ché cette ressemblance
ne gêne pas besoin non je lui demande
contre un sésame us plutôt d'avoir nous
sommes interchangeables je marie ses
paroissiens et le baptise miens
[Musique]
le ministre de la santé publique
monsieur bernard chesneau s'est vu
remettre le nouveau timbre pour la
campagne anti tuberculeuse 60 61
défendez vos enfants contre la
tuberculose tel en est le thème qui met
ainsi l'accent sur les devoirs des
parents trop de négligence sont en effet
à l'origine des ravages que la
tuberculose fait encore en france c'est
ainsi qu'il importe de ne pas négliger
les réactions tuberculinique négative
elles indiquent la nécessité de la
vaccination bcg devenue positive celle
de l'application d'antibiotiques capable
d'empêcher le développement d'une primo
infection attention inhabituelle
aujourd'hui et ce spectacle sera
peut-être demain celui qu'offriront à
certaines heures les ateliers et les
usines
cela s'appelle la gymnastique de pause
pour obvier à la fatigue nerveuse qui
guette les ouvrières astreinte à une
occupation minutieuse ou un rendement
intensifs on vient de mettre en jeu dans
la bonne ville de troyes la gymnastique
rythmique qui delince équidés contracte
marie pivot machine s'il vous plaît
musique et indications des mouvements
enregistrés sur magnétophone sont
diffusées dans toute l' usine à la
verticale les mouvements pratiques et
constitue une compensation de la
position de travail
[Musique]
à
et
éclaircies de nuque
[Musique]
aigri demain
clark et de hanches les pieds des cartes
et relevons le genou gauche
c'est ainsi que le centre
d'apprentissage de la bonneterie de 3
est devenu une sorte de centre pilote de
cette méthode qui un jour peut être
prochain aura droit de cité dans les
usines et les ateliers
[Musique]
c'est fait l'amérique a voté par tous
une affluence record s'est succédé dans
les bureaux de vote installés aussi bien
dans les drugstores que dans les écoles
venus de washington en hélicoptère le
président sortant a voté à gettysburg
alors que plus de 67 millions
d'américains chiffre jamais atteint
imiter son geste monsieur madame nixon
ont voté près de los angeles
ah oui tir et john kennedy à boston qui
ai commencé un peu le fief de sa famille
toute la nuit les journaux lumineux ont
proclamé les résultats en même temps que
dans les bureaux officiels et les
rédactions de journaux clip télé
printing la lutte d'abord favorable à
nixon inclinait enfin définitivement
pour kennedy et le candidat républicain
a accepté sportivement sa défaite
c'était pour kennedy et le parti
démocrate en marge du pouvoir depuis
deux législatures la victoire et le 35e
et lui 43 ans fortune et dynamique entre
aujourd'hui dans l'histoire des états
unis
john kennedy aux côtés de sa femme née
jacqueline bouvier va attendre son
entrée en fonction et son prochain bébé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]